Oh shit, sorry.
Guys, I've been so out of it, guys.
Oh yeah, I won a tournament.
I can chill as much as I want.
Let me fucking...
All right, let me get my chat in here.
Buy my controller.
I won a tournament.
This is my chat.
in the chat um let me just like let me fix this real quick i'm tired okay pre-order my controller before it's gone there you go one week left one week left to buy guys you know what else is a tournament winning uh item my fucking msi 500 hertz monitor i told you guys there's like got that monitor everything was different also i haven't even made the tweet about winning in tournament.
I'm going to yoying their screen.
I'm going to yoying someone's screenshot.
I'm going to, okay, what is uh, do you have a graphic of of us winning?
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
Um.
There's another VTuber tournament.
What the fuck?
The next day?
had another rival's tournament is crazy another vtuber rival's tournament it's crazy uh thank you guys i'm sorry i'm like i'm like so out of it like i'm so guys i want oh jen you're right what another i forgot bro things are blurring together guys i i actually i don't i don't know you guys remember but um you know how like after the interview i literally disassociated for like a couple of minutes like I was not okay I like right after I left the call with Connor and IMS I think it was just like I forgot I was like on I forgot I was streaming like I literally forgot that I was still streaming I thought like oh shit now I'm off stream I can I left the call and I was like it's over like i don't have to like i'm off like i'm not like i know i was like wait i'm streaming i i was like wait a minute oh wait i'm streaming too i forgot
yeah oh yes this is so seen because i it's just so much adrenaline and everything i need um i need to like no there it's youtube side that's so that sucks that um um uh that uh what was I gonna say oh yeah it sucks that my last game YouTube got hit got hit hard that was that was unfortunate but what could you do at least the did the VOD survive I was too scared to watch the VOD I watched a bit of the the replay on oh the VOD is fine that's good I watched a bit of the replay of the games themselves on on Seedog and Aramouse's stream.
Let's see how people were thinking.
I also watched a little bit of Shoto's POV during that unfortunate game that I had against them.
I need you guys to know, I was not, my hands were shaking the entire time for that very first game.
I was not aiming at all.
Like, I'm surprised I hit any shots.
During that first game.
So, um, I don't know if you guys know that.
I think you guys could tell.
And then after that, um, after, uh, after the first game, like, my aim, like, relaxed after that.
Um, it was fine after that, yeah.
Um, but like after the first game, I was fine with my aim.
Yo, you guys, you guys like how aggressive I was?
Because I, okay, like, I would never do this.
And, and if I was in my top 500.
lobby i would never been that aggressive but i knew i knew i could out aim at least 70 of at least 70 to 80 of the people in that tournament so i knew i could like even as rocket as rocket too because like they know but they don't expect the rocket damage is actually insane it rockets damage is insane up close and no one ever expects the rocket to shoot back so when i rock it all i was just like,
that's right, bitch.
I was just like, I was like, get over here.
I fucking mowed down an entire tank into like, to zero HP is crazy.
Uh, that's close.
But the thing is, I know I could get, I knew I could get away with it in this tournament.
Um, but, um, I, I, I obviously in rank, in rank because um all the fucking rank players like all the top 500 players would fucking shit on me and shut me down but i knew i knew like even as luna the moment i swapped the luna oh my god luna feels so slow after i started playing gambit for those who don't know luna is not meta anymore so that's why we avoided playing luna um and we only had to play luna during like certain scenarios like the storm vault you have to play luna for storm vault um So,
if she felt so slow when I was, like, swapping to Gambit, like, aim-wise as well.
Like, it was so weird trying to aim on Luna because I'm not used to aiming on Luna with, like, after playing Gambit for so long.
Like, yeah, she's finally freed.
We're finally free.
Yeah, I was glad that...
Now you guys can see why I was fucking...
guys can tell see that i would like 1v1 other players and i was that confident as as uh like there was i had so much mobility it's actually crazy as gambit you can have so much fucking ability you can see me like go in and then go out and i'm still alive like that's why yeah and um um i use gambit very aggressively the difference between a bad gambit and like a good gambit is um you use your abilities aggressively so you don't use it to heal you literally use it to just anti things and like you just play as anna that's really it um um and he's just like he like people are like oh he's the kierko he's he's the anna he's the anna of marvel rivals so and he has you can see like how if you guys ever when you were watching the games um and every time my back
instantly and like killed the dive that's why i was not afraid of like flankers everyone they're like oh what about the flankers i was like just mark them if you mark them i can kill them because i have so much like my kit is just so fucking strong yeah it's just so strong like um uh gash can you welcome to tamil find welcome welcome um uh fiction name is super chat thank you thank you unfortunately no but there is a way to watch the bots wink wink wink you might have to ask a dragon about it there is a way to still access the streams um but you have to ask a dragon about it because i i don't know um oh man yeah i heard heavenly like locked in with dps by playing like blasting music out and fucking just going ham.
Okay, I gotta make my my victory tweet real quick, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me see.
Let me make my victory be organizers for anything and understandings but amazing despite all the all the guys okay sorry i have to make my like my victory tweet before i go before we go back here because i don't want to um i don't want to uh wait too long for it because everyone's still sort of awake um anyway sorry i'm like all over the mine is all over place i'm i'm i cannot believe we won There's a controller vibe where I ask you for Yeah,
you can customize the Controller To have the, I heard that the The pro controller doesn't Have the vibration Only because Oh, wait, are you talking about Something else?
I thought he was Yeah, you customize it.
You can add it in With your own customization to it Don't, thank you for the Well, thank you for the 5 gift of ships Thank you, thank you, unless you mean something else Unless you mean something else.
All the setbacks and last minute.
All the setbacks.
Everything went.
The production.
The event itself went so smoothly.
And was so professionally done.
Thank you.
got top five okay i'm gonna be like what are the same day for mob for marvel rivals got top 500 and won the first vtuber cup posted by sea dog and iron mouse i really appreciate the organized for being amazing despite the events that went so smoothly and so professionally done um and so went so smoothly today on today it was so professionally done um i didn't expect to make to the finals and even winning the champ winning it all
I almost dropped out because wait should I say that I almost dropped out I literally had a breakdown last night because I almost dropped out no I don't need to add that yet I'll tell you guys the story okay Uh, dropping a little fun fact, guys.
Uh, felt, yeah, I was, I'd fucking, I was like, I hope we win one game.
I, because, like, I said, we literally, as a full team together, like, with all six of us, we had two hours together of all six of us.
And then, uh, five of us, we had four hours of practice.
But I literally saw some teams that were, like, um, in the VC for two days, morning to night, for hours.
And I was like, oh, no, are we not practicing enough?
I was, like, so scared.
And I was like, oh, my gosh, oh.
And then, like, you know, I was like, oh, we don't have, you know, we don't have a, we don't have, like, you know, like an X-Pro DPS player or like, like, in a top 500 DPS player, you know, or like in an X-Pro in different types of games or anything or just like,
you know, gifted, you know, you guys can be like, oh, dokey but you got top 500 in like overwatch and apex and stuff like that but like i play support now in rivals and that is because like you know like i would see like the enemy dps players like you know i would see sk or like blur like like just walking around and i couldn't do anything about it i have to like all i could do like i want to shoot them but i mean i did shot blur a couple of times and also SK a couple of times but it was very there were also very risky moves to take for me as a support because when I die my team doesn't get kills anymore so so um so like it was very risky for me to to try and take those shots to try and do one like like 1v1 against like the really,
really, really good DPS players.
So I was very nervous because we didn't, I guess like we didn't, our team was just very, very well-rounded.
Like we were so lucky to have such an amazing combination.
Like even though it was like assigned, pre-assigned, our team was just really good in terms of like, we're all just good, well-rounded individuals.
that we could literally just play anything yeah like we could play even though we're not all of our average was a bit lower uh was a bit lower compared to others um um we managed to like we were so flexible with everything yeah um and you know i know i i had really good igls and stuff like that i yeah oh my god i just watched the vod of them just i sorry i accidentally had a vod of the the Shoto match and then where the fuck did I come from where I just suddenly fucking killed the Magneto I don't know like I just saw Magneto die now like where the like by me I was like where the fuck did I come from like I'm sorry yeah yeah I was like yeah fuck you muted like fear what bitch like fear this
um um any any oh wait whoa the muted situation was crazy yeah yeah yeah heavenly was our secret weapon regarding like the flex uh being the flex like actual dp by the way he was he was he was the role he chose was dps um he was like my first choice is dps but we're but he was the strongest tank player in our entire team so we're like we're putting on tank um um because like obviously our other dps player was melee only so you know when they started playing flyers when they started fucking playing flyers we were like oh shit okay swap what are you gonna do punch them from the sky yeah that ain't season one iron fist bro like yeah
yeah it was our hawk like that's why i said don't say anything i told my team private your profiles don't say anything because they were all they all the other teams were analyzing our mains we're trying to figure out our mains and everything yeah uh oh can i get my second happy birthday from my oh she also congrats on winning a tournament gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you have your birthday is two days don't worry don't worry i'll still be here to wish you a Gordon happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear Gordon happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday yeah yeah he was yeah his Hawkeye got banned instantly but he was a he was literally a hitscan DPS player so like he could just play other hitscans like he was a hitscan projectile DPS player like he was our non melee character so it didn't matter if they Target band,
Hawkeye, because he could still play, you know, he could still fucking play, like, the other gun shooty DPS play, DPS, yeah, um, uh, so, yeah, I'm just, I'm really fucking, uh, proud of my team for it, um, I, bro, like, the amount of, like, I literally woke up,
five, uh, I woke up at, like, 10, a.m yeah i woke up at 10 a.m and started researching today because i started researching um my teams because like uh started researching all the like all the enemy teams and stuff because okay this is like really fucked up but like um i know like others were doing the same like there was a lot of money on the line too and like you know uh others were also doing something so i assume others were doing something similar because i saw people private their profiles um after joining the But like,
I know it's like pretty messed up, but it's research.
I like, that's, I find this fun.
I find the strategizing and trying, like, trying to figure out, like, what to play against.
Because that's, that's literally competitive.
Like, you can say, like, oh, it's for fun.
But like, that's, it's still competitive in a way.
Like, it's still a competitive environment.
yeah i did for the love of the game but and i love i love like the strategies and like strategize because it's rock paper scissors bandline is rock paper scissors um if you get a good bandline you fucking win the game so uh so like what i did basically i don't know i think i said it before but i looked up everybody's profiles like one by one because they uh gave us access to uids um and I looked it up one by one and then all the ones that had their profiles open I looked at history and then I see all the comps they played together in the six stack so that's that's literally what I did and um so and then like also if they are open I see what they mean I just look at what they made and see the thing is this is what my bad line was I look for players I look for players who have been who are newer in the game and if they're playing important This is why our team was the only team that banned Emma because from my research Um,
this is the only reason why our like though other all the other teams they didn't ban Emma What I noticed because, uh, they had their profiles open was that I realized Um, I realized that they only they only had time to learn one new character and emma their only tank player learned all they did was learn emma for like their and their second most played tank was mag with 11 minutes so they i noticed that oh wait they're only their main only tank player and you guys remember in the VOD in the VOD where uh where they were like where I was like guys read what my discord message because we were watching we were watching uh we were watching dubie and amelie's I think it was like yeah dubie versus amelie and then uh amelie versus uh uh fuck oh my gosh my mind is blurring together who is the 13 this who is the 13 guys it was uh Shoto.
It was Amalee versus Shoto.
And what I typed in the Discord was like, do you notice how they are playing one tank and their one tank is their Emma player?
Like...
So my brain is like frazzled right now because I've been doing a lot of thinking.
And that was why I was typing in the Discord server.
And I was like, don't be afraid.
They're literally playing one tank and their one tank is their Emma one trick.
And that's why I banned Emma You know how I got this strat?
Because fucking XQC during the XQC tournament, Target Band Tyler won.
Despite our team being incredibly stacked.
And all Tyler won did.
Great guy.
Very funny.
But all he did on Hulk when we did a D1 XQC, Target Band are poor new player who can only play Venom.
He targeted Ben Tyler 1 We were We won a majority of our games XQC lost all his games We went to knockout stages And XQC's team Knocked us out Because they realized Wait Tyler 1 can only play Venom And then we had to put Tyler 1 On Hulk and he fucking fed his ass off and then we got knocked out we were the favorites to get first or second and then we got knocked out and from that was where I learned my lesson
this was where I realized this was the strat because my team was like no we shouldn't Emma, we have to ban Hella and Siloc.
I was like, no, you don't understand.
It was a life lesson.
That what he did to us was a fucking life lesson.
And then after we got knocked out by XKC's team, when we were the favorites, like instantly gone.
It was like group stages and we got he lost every game.
We won every game.
So we're like, this is easy.
You know, like, oh, we're against the team that lost every game.
Like, we're supposed to win this and then he they realized wait we can target bad tyler one because that's their second tank and then everything fell apart because it became a 5v6 because tyler one had to learn an entire new tank during that during that one that like live on that game uh So my team was like,
no, no, bad Hela Silos, because they were very scary.
Because we don't want to deal with Namor Team Up with Hela.
And also, we don't want to deal with SK Silos.
And I was like, no, guys, we have to ban Emma.
You don't understand.
Their main tank player can only play Emma.
At the moment we take that away from him, their entire front line collapses.
I was like, you don't understand.
Like, and then they're like, and I pulled up the excuse me thing.
It happened to me in this tournament.
You don't understand.
I literally got knocked off because of that.
Like,
I was like, we have to do this.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, so.
so like because you know having you know they lost their main tank so like the the the strat was just basically by losing their main tank because it's very hard to learn a new character after spending hours on the one tank you know the one character that you were told to learn uh for the last two days and suddenly bam the band went in like so so it essentially becomes a 5v6.
Okay, also, the other thing was that I was going to try and ban Hella too after that.
I was going to be like Emma Hella because I was like, let's give Eski SILOC because I feel bad because like she was Target bad the entire time.
And then obviously my team was like, don't do that, bro.
You're like, because like, you know, Yannirs has only played Hella the entire time.
And I was like, bro, let's just let Eski play SILOC, man.
She got Target bad.
And then my team was like, no, that's bullying you're gonna you're bullying the two new players for my batting their new their characters and i was like but i just want to give eskade siloed and that's why i was like let's gotcha it guys let's but then but then we got domination i was like no gotcha i ain't fighting siloed on domination i okay it was because we were guaranteed in the final so at that point i didn't care whether we I was like,
no, I don't want to die to Scylok on domination because domination is the best map for Scylok So I was like, no, I was gonna be nice, but never mind I was just like, I just hated playing domination with Scylok, like against Scylok I was just like, I'm sorry,
the map picked the map didn't want me like
Yeah, that one map changed my entire my entire career
yeah um jacquardo thank you super chat thank you thank you some may underestimate dokey coming out with big brain stress because they don't expect research mode dokey but when it's rival she uses 110 of the brain thank you super chat i think i could be i i don't think i actually no i don't think i'm a good analyst honestly i had a lot of help from um figuring out how to analyze situations um from other pro players just watching pros and like just talking to other pro players and also like talking to like the managers of uh pro teams so it helped a lot trying to figure because like you know i was very undecided about some things so like so like they helped me a lot when they um when they were like teaching me how to analyze the situation because i also didn't play this season a lot that's also because like like i literally started this season three days ago I I literally started this season three days ago so I was like not not like not like very informed like I wasn't very informative
of like what to fucking swap you know like I was like do I do this or do I do that like because I was very like I'm very proud of my team for being able to like think for themselves about counterswapping too so I'm glad that they also thought for themselves as well um and being able to like because when i don't know what to counter swap i was just like just they they were like i'll do this then but i did like i did like been more pro i was very proactive in the end about counter swapping because like i didn't want people them to hesitate because i was like we got i like i was just like guys come on guys we got we got we have to like think really fast because i like the thing about me because i have the game a top 500 hiring player so um um you know we our duty as like especially a support player we have to react fast basically we have to react and think very fast about the situation because like one second can cost like the entire game so i have to like be like i actually have to take
control about the swapping be like swap now swap that swap now swap this like i was like he's I was like, he's Moon Knight.
Go, go back to spawn room and go get off of Loki.
And then the user was like, wait, right now?
Like, the game's like, yes, right now.
Yes, right now.
Get off of Loki.
Like, I don't care if you have...
Yeah, I realized, like, after the first map, I had to be more...
I have to be more proactive with calling for swaps and stuff.
It's because, like, I am also used to it for, you know, I started playing competitive in Overwatch, and Overwatch was all about counterswapping, and so you had to think fast.
And then Apex, it's all about rotations and everything.
And so that taught me about, like, rotations and, like, positioning and stuff.
And so, like, combining those two into rivals, Helped out a lot.
I was really impressed with how you're able to micromanage just enough to wrangle your team.
Yeah, it's very hard on Gambit because Gambit has a lot of things to do.
So like my brain was actually on fucking overtime trying to figure out like what to Like what to say what to do on Gambit only because like I have like 50 other buttons to play use like and like be aware of my surroundings too.
Okay, but yeah out um i'm glad i was able to play gambit because i don't know if you guys noticed but gambit is a very very broken like i literally got to okay you guys do notice because i always i'm so humbled but i sort of talk about it a bit you know you know i sort of talk about it here and there but you know how i got top 500 in two days by playing gambit yeah but he is so good on um he is he is the best support character like in this game and i'm there's no way they're keeping him like that and there's no way they're keeping him like that though because rank one two three four and five currently is literally one guy one pro player who just plays gambit and he got rank one two three and four and five right now and his play style is basically i basically took my play style is basically his play style i took how i've analyzed how he plays and i just played like him yeah that's that's how fucking broken gambit is at the moment yeah His name is Saipay,
but yeah, he's like rank 1 to 5 at the moment on Gambit.
So, that's why you see how aggressive, like, I do heal.
Like, I'd never use my heals.
You can tell that I'd never use my healing cards.
And all I did was just anti-people over and over again.
Because, like, his primary heal is just so strong already.
So, like, it doesn't, like, he doesn't need to use his cards to heal.
because it takes fucking forever to charge.
It's a good...
I'm actually having a lot of fun playing Gambit, too.
Yeah, his anti-heal is just way too strong to use it for anything else.
Like I said, it's just Anna.
It's just really Anna.
Oh, sorry.
But, yeah, okay, I forgot.
Fuck, I was supposed to make my tweet.
Yeah, sorry.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I was supposed to make my tweet, and I forgot it.
Okay.
so i didn't expect to make it uneven winning it it all so i really couldn't i really couldn't have done it done it without my team so please check them out they're all wonderful players who deserve um they're all wonderful players well a wonderful
Insane Fraggers.
Uh, and then I'll do the Twitter ads.
Okay, what's their Twitter ad?
I don't remember what their Twitter ad is.
I know Isa made a tweet, so I'm just yonking that.
Uh, I'm just gonna yonk that real quick.
Uh, thanks Isa.
Let me copy your homework, but I'll change it a little bit.
Okay.
Heavenly.
all right and then isa no one can tell her i'm literally i'm just taking her i'm just taking her fucking twitter handle thing i'm just copying pasting that because she did the thing uh
i didn't eat dinner yet by the way i lied i know i said let me push a 30 minutes to grab dinner and I didn't eat dinner.
Alright, I appreciate Orangers for being amazing.
Despite all the setbacks of the event, despite all the setbacks, events that went so smoothly and was so perfect, so smoothly today and was so professional.
I didn't expect to make it all the way to the finals.
uh, and even when I really couldn't have done one of my teams, so please check out my own wonderful, insane braggers.
And made me so proud.
Also, huge shout out.
Also, huge shout out to our coach.
At Super.
To our coach, too.
Okay, let me add that.
Also, huge shout out to our coach, too.
Who helped us.
Who helped us with.
who helped us figure out comps and how to play no, you know what yeah, just, yeah, there you go who helped us find scrims and wait, I don't know how to say who helped us, did I say that?
I don't know if I should give too much detail like
yeah that's it to our coach there you go yeah there you are to say also huge shout out to your coach too yeah i'm tired i'm tired thank you every who helped us who helped us prepare and stayed up to give individual coaching for those who wanted it yeah I shouldn't know he didn't stay up,
lie.
Sorry, he didn't stay up.
He left after an hour or two.
I don't know how long he stayed because I was doing my endurance battlefield stream.
I didn't know.
It still counts.
Oh.
Thank you, everyone, for supporting me and my team.
Me and my team.
All right.
I'm so happy to have made it this far.
There you go.
No dinner because Jolly Bee was gone.
closed, sad face.
I love the air that you would see.
Oh my gosh, I'm so tired.
My eyes actually, like, feel so heavy.
I think it's like, I'm not tired.
I think I'm, like, I'm not, like, physically tired.
I'm, like, mentally tired.
I think that that's it.
I don't physically feel tired.
I'm just mentally so exhausted.
From, because I had to use...
so much of my brain power to play that entire tournament because I was, you know, I was watching some of the other streams.
I think my biggest advantage was that I have so much experience in tournaments that like I know how to lead a team in terms of like IGLing because I have so much experience
rank lobbies that like um um it gave our team an advantage because then we knew what to do like we had a plan each time we don't hesitate to so like that was like our one of our big because i was watching like the other like i was watching like i think like two of the povs i didn't i didn't watch dubie's pov for like her matches but um like the there was no like i guess there was were all trying to like decide as a team on what to do and what not to do but for me i was like no we're doing this you know they're like do it yeah i was like no we're doing this i was like you you do this we're gonna do this next and then we're gonna do this next i was like don't all everyone do not all but like yeah yeah i'll be like uh uh i was like Yuzu,
don't come out.
Keep hiding.
Yeah, because I know Yuzu wants to join the fight.
And I was like, Yuzu, don't come out of the hole.
Keep fucking hiding.
and I'm like, don't awe, and then Heavenly throws his awe.
And I'm like, bro!
And so, Luna, the thing is, um i know kikio was very shy um she was a she's a very shy player apparently um gomez told me that when i wasn't in the college she talked a lot so i think she was very intimidated by me um like because like he was doing individual coaching um for anyone that wants it and he was doing individual coaching for anyone that wanted like you know extra help like while i was playing
struggling playing battlefield and he told me that um there was like four of them in the car and she was like yapping a lot and like she's like you were just very he was like yeah you're like you're very intimidating yeah when i get like super serious you know i get super serious uh um during like uh when you know because i i love competitive games in general so I didn't,
she didn't say she didn't have all, you know, she could, you know, she was, I was like, Luna, oh, Luna, oh, because I didn't see her all, I didn't realize she all did, because I think I was dead, um, so I saved my all, because I was waiting for her to all,
um, and then I tapped, I was like, oh, you didn't have all, I was just like, uh, I was like, oh, wait, I pressed tab, I was like, wait, no, never mind, you didn't have all, I was like, what the fuck, why aren't you all, but she didn't say anything, She didn't say anything until I pressed staff.
Yeah.
Yeah, she was so scared to tell me she didn't have, oh, yeah.
I'm just glad that we still won the fight, though.
Yeah, the others had to say it, yeah.
Oh, yeah, fucking, give me a sec.
I still need to finish my tweet.
I'm still trying to finish my tweet.
I'm still.
My God, I forgot to make a waiting room, too, for this stream.
Like, I was all over the place, guys.
I was all over the place.
Like, I still haven't.
Okay, what a sane day for Marvel rivals.
God, top 500, won the first video cup hosted by C-Dog and RMS.
I really appreciate the audience for being amazing, despite all the setbacks.
It went so smooth in the day and was so professional in that.
And I didn't expect to marry all the fans and even winning it all.
Okay, I love my team, so please check out the all-wonderful and insane fraggers.
It made me so proud.
Um, each of them played a huge part, huge part in our victory.
And her coach who helped us prepare.
Um, and, yeah.
Everyone who's around my team, I'm so happy to have made it this far.
Uh, W event.
I should say that.
W.
Um, um, uh, thank you, everyone!
Where's the word of my team?
I said, how to make it this, to have made it this far, to have made it this far.
Um, and I'm just so proud of everyone.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, let me grab a screenshot.
I'm gonna grab my top 500 screenshot and put it.
And include it as well.
okay all right let's see when did i guys when did i okay time stamp time i'm looking at time stamp when i include my top five showed you guys my top 500 okay top five guys did you guys not time stamp it okay okay guys where's the time stamp i'm taking a screenshot no it was after i we got into the finals and i was like i oh yeah when we got confirmed to be in the finals where is it no the lag made no it was like before we were in the finals okay get second point uh where is it wins to uh gets final push i don't know okay winning wait where is it it's somewhere
uh okay here you are all right here we are okay this is where all right time stamps were like yeah sorry i'm so sorry it was it was literally youtube side i was literally watching i was literally like my i was watching streams and stuff and it didn't buffer at all i was so surprised all right let me grab a screenshot real quick oh yeah by the way like i said um i'm in another in um next month but this time it's like it's it's like uh other it's like pro players and content creators uh but like they're making sure that we each get our own like we each are like like you know it's like drafting it's like a drafting phase and also uh they're divided by roles so they got like people like fill up every role and stuff and everything so it's not like,
uh, um, it's not like, you know, oh, what's the word?
Sorry, my brain is so fried.
Like, they're like, okay, like each captain has to draft a support and then, you know, grab a support.
Each captain has to grab this, like that and that, like, yeah, basically has to grab like a content creator or some shit, like, all right, here you go.
All right, there you go.
Oh my gosh, give me a sec.
I'm trying to find.
All right, here you go.
I'm going to grab that screenshot, guys.
That screenshot of me getting a top 500, everyone.
Whoa, there we go.
Hee-hee.
There we go.
What a wonderful day.
All right, here is my top 500.
And then I'm going to yonk Isas.
Okay, now I won't yonk Isas.
I'm going to look at...
all right when did we win I'm glad that they let us restart the map too I'm glad I'm really happy about that because I felt so bad I felt so bad that requested I requested a map like you know be like please honor this band you know I'm very happy that they honored it I got really worried that they were like no
Yeah, I was weird to be like, no, wait, is the VOD okay?
Is it laggy?
I can't tell.
Wait, let me.
Like, it's the VOD okay?
Oh, VOD is okay, okay.
The VODs are okay, okay, good.
That's good.
Okay, I think it's still, yeah.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm glad.
All right, let me...
Victory dokeybird.
I'm gonna...
And then...
I don't know.
Do I get the one where...
Do I use the screenshot where they're like...
VTuber cup standings?
Or do I...
Ooh, the victory.
Okay, maybe I'll do victory.
Uh...
You know, I'm gonna grab the Connor...
Connor video.
Let's see.
There we go.
standings there we go I'll grab that bucket there we go all right insane also to oh yeah thank you okay also insane fights against insane games against every everyone my my brain had to go full full nerd mode to figure out how to how figure out how to counter everyone how to let's see count okay awesome games games against all all the teams my brain i go full nerd mode figure out how to counter each and Every fight.
Go for nerd mode.
Uh, yeah, it keeps getting longer and longer.
I'm sorry.
I'm tired.
My, okay, I'll show you guys my spreadsheet.
I'll show it to you guys.
It's live.
here you go okay this is me okay wait let me
there you go okay this is not all of it though
i'll show you guys my spreadsheet there's more by the way to it i have like one where it's like our main comps what do we play when that they do this but i'll show you this oh yeah let's see actually okay uh oh yeah let me double check everything i wrote here did i wrote anything bad no i didn't okay there you go yeah there you go team showdo release the documents these are our bad line They also have a strong side lock.
Here's our...
This is why I posted it, so I just look at it whenever.
And these are, like...
They have an anti-ban...
I was like, what maps are Angela?
You know?
And then...
And then there's, like, Dubee's team.
The Dubee files.
Yeah, and then, here you go.
Here's our bantering scrims, because they did a scrim.
They did a scrim against, like...
But I should have told them like they're fucking around like and these are not the actual comps you're playing because I know their quick play comps were the real comps They did a scrim like doobie and shoto screamed each other and And but they were fucking around with their comps for it and also their band line So I knew that this wasn't a real comps and I looked at the quick play and that's where I found the real comps Because I was like yeah like if they're six stacking quick play playing their actual real comps because it was consistent and then so i was like hella's main band and penny obviously we swapped that around later uh i swapped that around later after that because i was just like oh uh we later were like we bad bucky hella uh because we realized um at first we're like oh all of them could play penny and then we're like oh wait no bucky hella is a better strat just because like we saw we saw you know the first what dubie and amalie were the was the first team to play
against each other so um we noticed that blur was really good at bucky so we swapped our band line or i swapped the band line and was like okay we ban um hella and bucky um and uh at first we wanted to ban group because we realized they only play group uh we they really only played group so then i was just like but so That was like we're doing the same thing as like ban Emma because that's the only thing they play But then we're like oh,
it's fine.
Like their DPS is a lot scarier than like because their tanks can swap to something else Even though they have to swap to uh, they have to swap to a DPS but um We just realized just bucky we don't want to deal with bucky up because we have a low key And also like you know they had to play moon knight to counter our low key and we so we're like you know,
he's just going to farm our clones.
And we're like, Hella, we don't want to deal with the team up because we notice how good they are at the team up.
So we don't have a Hella and a Namor player.
And this was our second one here.
Oh, that's...
So yeah, ban Emma.
Yeah, that's...
They have a player that only knows how to play Emma.
So...
there it is and then my team argued against it and was like um my team was like no don't ban emma we have to ban hella we have to ban hella because it's scary the name where team up is scary i was like no i played these games before i i was like i play these i got knocked out because my trick could only play venom and we were the favorites and we got knocked out by the by the last place team because they banned my one chick i was not having history repeat itself
yeah that's like my strategy i was like get rid of the front line
so so my strat was to get rid of the front line because like i said when the front line falls everything falls thank you pat thank you xqc for giving me enough trauma to do this to someone else like i continue the cycle i
continue this cycle.
Okay, give me, I'm making the tweet.
Uh, games against all the teams, remember how to count each and every fight.
Um.
Um, you were all a pleasure.
You were all pleasure to to play against um do we i'm gonna leave should all put up a great a great fight uh okay there you are i did the tweet okay before the tournament oh yeah
oh yeah
honor and strategic guys strategize and say everyone on the flat
team doobie all right there we go all right here uh
insane games against all right here this is a long ass tweet but i feel like it says everything i want to say hippie there you go There you go.
I made my tweet.
Alright.
I did it.
Yippee.
My little yippee.
No dub.
We got yippee.
What's... I think yippee is better than W event, guys.
W event.
If you guys want to just reply W event to my tweet, if you want.
Like...
You guys can write W event in my reply.
If you really want to.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
Can't believe they target bad me.
I'm just a support player.
I'm just a support player, guys.
how come i got targeted um but oh but oh bum bum all right okay so i'll tell you guys more about the details okay so i almost dropped out um of the obvious the whole i mean that's basically the whole story i almost dropped out of the tournament because i was so stressed out and like i've been very stressed out the last month and um there was like a lot of like balancing stuff going on last minute a lot of people being um replaced and everything and then i felt so bad because um i didn't also i didn't really want to be captain i didn't want to be captain at all um because like you know i feel like if we could make our own name instead of being like team dokeybird you know like that would be less stressful but it was like team dokeybird i represent the entire team and then you know i and the fact that i had to do like the interviews and everything and like and like i knew it because i was captain i have to do the interviews and stuff so it was like so much and there was so much so many
eyes on me like literally when they announced it everyone was like yo keeper it's gonna sweep the entire tournament and everything and there was so much pressure on me because everyone knows that i'm like the marvel rivals vtuber and so like but then i got really nervous because when we were seeing when we got our team thing when we got the team list uh um I was very worried because like I said it was 70% support players so a lot of people had to off-roll and we didn't really have like you know like pure tank players so people that's why that's also why I was so aggressive I um I got like that's why I was so aggressive because I knew a lot of people are off-rolling so like even the tanks so I knew like an actual tank player would fucking shut me down instantly um so but I knew I was like you're off-rolling you know I was like you you're off-rolling I'm coming for you like that's I was just like I was like fucking fighting everyone because i knew they were off rolling um so i was not
scared because they don't they don't know their uh their full potential as that character because if you saw me go up against the strange you know what i'm told at i'm like told that like never as a support player never try not even as a support or dps player you're never supposed to do a 1v1 against will always win the fight but i was like you were off rolling i know you don't know how to kill me like so i'm also like punishing too because i was like i know you don't know how to kill me bro
so so that's why i was so fucking aggressive because i knew a lot of the people were off rolling so and same with my team like i said we didn't really have a tank player um but balina was a was a melee dps player he all he mostly plays like um he mostly plays all like iron fist and mr fantastic which is a crazy hero pool like so we had to stick heavenly onto tank and um isa was was our dps player as well but um we realized that a lot of lower elo low ranked players or like you know the rank disparity of players they don't know how to play against iron fist and mr fantastic so especially when iron fist that has a team supporting him um that's why and because teams already struggle with dare devil like if he knew dare to little it would have been perfect but if he knew dare devil it would have been so not fair right um because dare double is like the fucking um the fucking most broken dps character right now in in rivals um uh but like even then like there's also like it um if they knew
like they just need a bucky to counter that's why we were banning bucky too because bucky counters iron fist as well um um so so i was you know i was really nervous about it because, um, um, a lot of the other teams, they had really, really good DPS players,
um, that were, like, you know, um, that were, like, even if they were not, even if their ranking rivals isn't high, they've, like, peaked higher in different games, and, um, or they have, like, a higher rank average.
Our rank average was not that high.
Uh, like, you know, users literally learned the game two days.
not learn the learn the game but literally um try to pick up the game two days ago um i mean she i think she played quick play before when the game first came out but you know she didn't play a lot she was unranked like she ranked like she got into rank like two days ago and everything um so she had like i had to coach her and kikyu on how to play support because during the first scrims i had like guide them on support all like how to support all and everything because during the scrim yuzu um i don't know if this was during the tournament was this i don't remember if it was a tournament or the scrim but she didn't know when she didn't know which characters was uh which character which copy on loki for loki was uh um for sorry i'm remembering strasel was for aggressive was for defense so I had to teach her that because she was using Luna aggressively.
I was just like, no that's our only defense on, Yuzu.
Stop!
So I was like, don't do that again, Yuzu.
She was just like, I was like, okay, I'm gonna cop.
I was like, okay, we're gonna copy.
We're gonna use it defensively and then she copied Luna and like ran into the enemy team.
And I was like, our only defense on.
And then she's like sorry because like you know before then she was copying she was copying me non-stop and i always play the aggressive of it but i was like don't copy because and i had to swap to i had to swap to uh rocket i think um because of the comp and and so she i was like copy luna you have to copy luna don't copy me and so she thought that because i was like don't copy rocket you I was just like,
Luna was just better than Rocket.
So I was a teacher and be like, okay, just copy our Luna and use it defensively.
But then she was like, oh, I don't know which character is like afterwards.
You know, after she's like, sorry, I didn't know which one's defensive.
I was like, aggressively, Mantis and Gabbit.
That's it.
Like, everything else, defensively.
So from there, I was like, and then also Kikyo.
Like I said, I was coaching our support player.
because obviously, you know, I have more of the game sense and knowledge.
I had to teach Kikyo to be like, I'm lucky that no one know how to play Phoenix in the tournament, but I wasn't sure sure because, well, I know, like, Blur can play Phoenix because he's, like, versatile and also SK.
I know Blur and SK need to play Phoenix, but I was like, okay, at first, Kikyo would throw Rocket Alts into Phoenix Alts.
Like, when we, you know, because it's, like, stuff like this.
Like, if you know the enemy team has a Phoenix, um you you don't oh it's like playing chicken like that's how you have to play against phoenix when you're rocket so i was just like so at first she like altered she altered before knowing we knew phoenix has alt but she still altered so i was just like during the scrims so i was just like quickly was like yeah don't do that next time you play chicken you hold your rocket up and and because i don't trust my team to shoot the phoenix because we were literally together in two days i don't think we were that coordinated to shoot the fucking phoenix all um so i was just like i was like okay we just wait until the phoenix all then you all next time like stuff like that i was giving like like for me this is very common knowledge for me because you know if i don't do it i get fucking yelled at and i'll start crying um i get yelled at by my team and then i'm gonna start crying so i had to go through that you know so but so that's why common
knowledge for me but like you know a lot of these players are not in my rank um my rank to like have that being yelled at them so so I had to like teach them and be like yeah just make sure to do this and yeah we learn when we cry so um I had to like guide them along on um but our team
Um, because, like, you know, like I said, even though I'm considered one above all, I'm still a support player, so as a support player, I know, like, you're like, oh, but you guys, you kept everyone up and everything.
But also, like, I think what helped me was I could be any role.
If I was DPS or tank, if I was DPS or tank, and I was one above all DPS or tank, and I was also IGLing, I could get like 40 kills or like, you know, like 30.
plus final hits as a tank or DPS and also IGL, which will leave a much bigger impact for my team.
But as support, all I could really do is just give them knowledge, give them comms, and just keep them alive enough to enable them to do as much as they can through the knowledge and the damn brag.
No, it's true.
It's true.
You want to know why?
Because Super Gomez had the ring for Heavenly because he couldn't show up yesterday for scrims.
And, like, when we won our first game, he was, like, IGLing for us.
And he had 30 final hits.
And he had 30 plus final hits.
And IGLing for us.
And, like, we won against a...
We were scrimming against a...
Yeah, and then I was like, please play more like Heavenly.
Like, because I was like, he's not going to get 30 plus final hits on Tink, bro.
You got to play more like a diamond player.
Like, yeah, I was like, bro, you got to play more like a diamond player, bro.
He's not going to be doing the shit you're doing, man.
I mean, it's so important.
Yeah, they are.
They're very important.
But I would have a much bigger impact as a DPS and tank.
Because, like, I was a one above all DPS player.
Also, I wouldn't do, I would try not to do, like, I would be like, pop, pop.
Maybe sitting, so do it fade off and teach your teammates.
Zyka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This ain't a realistic scenario.
Yeah.
um um yeah so uh so i was really worried because like i got really worried because like i said i saw the team averages and everything and we had like you know we had diamond players we had diamond play we have i think like uh two diamond players we had two diamond players two celestial play So we had two,
we had me, and then we had an underrank.
And there was some teams that had, like, two Eternities, two Celestias, and a Platte.
And there was, like, one that was, like, GM, but I know you're very good at DPS.
Like, I don't remember the average for that, but...
And then there was also an Eternity player, GM player, Celestia player.
Like, it was...
I got really worried, because, like, the second highest...
I got really worried.
for like our team and then everyone's practicing like mornington like everyone was practicing so much i saw everyone just hanging on the vc and i'm like oh shit is it bad that we're not hanging out in the vc also i joined the server late too so that was my fault as well there were a lot of things that were my fault um so because like um i we could have had three days of practice but our team had two days because i joined the server late like so as captain i didn't organize stuff in time for my team because um i joined the server technically like almost a day late so other teams had three days of practice and my team had two days of practice because of that um because they were asking okay it was my fault and i felt so bad i like apologized and everything i'm like I'm sorry for causing such an issue and such a commotion about it But it was whether or not I wanted to be captain or not Because I didn't want to be captain I didn't want the responsibility So I joined the server late Because
me and the organizers were trying to figure out If I wanted to be captain or not So
It's so So that's why I joined this.
I felt so bad.
Because I was like, I didn't want the responsibility.
I was so scared and nervous.
It's like so much pressure.
And it wasn't the highest rank, though.
There's players that were higher rank that were captain.
What are you talking about in some of the teams?
Like, I think like the other three teams, it wasn't based on rank.
talking about the other three teams weren't even based on rake but mine was so i was i was like that's why i didn't that's why i had that whole discussion with guys like i don't want to be captain because like like if i lose they'll be like team donkey bird and then i have to go to a loser's interview and i was just like bro i don't know about the mental state right now they go guys no you don't understand i know you guys are like oh well but others had to lose they were doing those interviews,
but guys, I don't, I was already like, not okay.
Like, I was, I was just not okay, you know, like, no, I was just like, I was, I had a lot of stuff going on, and I was, like, super stressed out.
That was, like, super stressed out, and, like, um, um, a lot of stuff going on, and I was just like, pro, I'm, I'm, I don't know, I don't want this to be another one like minus one in stress or plus one plus one in stress so that's why i was like i don't know i won't be captain man like it's like also my luck has been really really bad lately so i don't know like like i've had some really bad luck things happening to me so i was like oh my god this might be another plus one
in gotcha too yeah yeah gotcha was not okay it was not on my side like after that dispatch no no I think dispatch was my breaking point I this match was my breaking because that was it was at the no it was sorry battlefield yeah and then the fact that it took a six out that was the day the six plus hours of battlefield was the day I crashed out and had a breakdown about whether or not I should drop out like that was that day because i was like i played battlefield it took us six plus hours to win and then the day before that i fucked up 385 like roles in dispatch and so yeah so i was just like i don't know so i was like this close and a huge shout out to the organizers because like they had to put up with me crashing out last night,
whether or not like, like, uh, whether or not I was like, I was like, I was gonna be okay, like, but also, it's such a sea dog deal, because they're like, you want to talk to sea dog?
I was like, I'm too embarrassed, man.
I feel so bad being, like, such a nuisance right now.
Um, I, I was like, I felt so bad.
I was just like, I'm sorry.
I don't like reached out to me himself you know I was like I don't want to talk to see dog because I'm very embarrassed and he still DMed me about it and being like are you okay because I was like bro my mental is like not good at the moment today and even he like reached like him and the organizer reached out and was like no we get it we understand we just want to make sure your mental is okay and I'm like I'll try so so I'm at like I was like what if we don't win anything Like,
what if we don't even win one game?
Like, I was barely that fucking deep.
Like, I was just like, I was like, what do we, what if we don't even win one game?
Like, what would I do?
I can't show my face to rivals.
I can't.
I can.
I was, I was absolutely going to doom queue for six hours until Good Night Dragons.
No, JK, you know I would.
You know I would instantly, because that's what I've always done.
You knew I was going to doom cube for like three plus hours Right after we didn't win a single game Like
If we lose just goes ahead and wins You guys find a smile for your talent Gora, thank you for the super chat Thank you No, yeah, because I did it before and I knew I was going to do it again And then it's like eight hours hours later and so yeah the obviously the most mentally healthy thing to do um so yeah no I'm yeah I'm so happy that's what I'm really proud of my team I'm so proud of my team for being able to pull this off so a fucking huge shout out to all the individual players um in my team um but yeah Yuzu,
Isa, uh, Heavenly, um, and Gomez for coaching, like, huge shout out to my entire team for, uh, for, you know, playing so fucking well, because it's a team game.
It's, oh, it is overall a team game, and I think each of them individually played a part in the victory, like, each had their own fucking moments that clutched it up for everyone, um, you know, they all had their insane plays and they all had their own plays that won us certain maps or certain points and everything um so yeah no they they like i i'm sorry for doubting my team i i'm sorry for doubting myself i was doubting myself because i was like i was i was like what if i felt so bad because they're like oh i brought up my team average you know um i was like oh no i brought up my team average I was gonna feel so fucking bad if we lose because of me because you know I was like oh you guys could have got like a better player than me like or like an actual high ranker DPS player or high rank tank player so um so I'm just really proud of them um I know some oh my gosh I saw like um I'm glad they did balance stuff again even though it was last minute because like um alma lee's team was
originally gonna have like uh another eternity support player versus like because like versus like uh because like sk was supposed to be on a different that's why there were so many like swaps and changes because sk was supposed to be on another team and alma lee was was gonna be like have like another eternity support player but they swapped it up uh and gave at the Like,
I think it was, like, three days before the tournament and put SK on Amelie's team.
And I think that definitely helped balance it a lot more, too.
So, I mean, they did a lot of swaps and stuff.
But, yeah, SK was originally not even going to be on Amelie's team because of, because, like, I think I, I think, like, some people brought it up, too, where, like, I'm in these team needs an TPS player.
Oh, yeah, I remember.
I remember I told you guys I was like bro some teams have five support players and one tank I remember when I said that chat I was like bro what the fuck there's one that's what that was Amelie's team I was like bro bro this team has five support players and one tank bro I was just like and then they yeah and then and then later on they like swapped SK onto that team to give them a dps player because because i think like some people were like yeah that's like rough yeah i remember now i was like bro that's fucking rough buddy
yeah uh yeah so i was just like oh my god uh The healer, he'll stop for the win.
So I'm glad they did that.
I thought Amelie's team was so strong.
I honestly, I think they had a lot of really, really close games.
I think the issue was just counterswapping.
Like I said, Amelie's team was very, very strong in general.
Like on paper.
They were very strong on paper and a lot of us were very scared.
very scared um because of it i think it's just more so of uh of just like it's just counter counter swapping rock paper scissors it's literally that um they just it just had to be like they just and also the fact that we all target bond to silo because we are not dealing with that every team was balanced in the end yeah
about balancing and stuff um so i'm glad like every uh team was balanced that was my biggest worry that's why i almost dropped out too because i was like oh my gosh like i don't know if this is balanced so like i was just like i don't know i don't know if it's gonna be balanced because everyone's playing off-rolls and stuff and i don't know what their skill level is and
um um but i know that's that's basically it i'm i'm i'm happy with how uh everything came out in the end you know i was expecting the worst possible outcome but then you know it's always nice to be pleasantly surprised that's why i was expect i don't know i know like i have like you know It's like,
like, what is it called?
What is it called?
Debbie Downer, you know, the typical Debbie Downer shit.
But like, I don't want to go in with high expectations because I don't want to be disappointed.
I don't want to be disappointed.
So I'm glad things were down.
Pleasantly, you mean like fucking first place?
Yeah, yeah, you'd be pleasantly surprised.
First place, guys.
Yeah, doomer.
Yeah, I got like doom.
I'm like doomer.
Oh my god.
Tomorrow I'm playing art creators.
I'm so tired I'm freaking oh my god.
Wait, I need to check my schedule.
Don't I have like other stuff I have to do in the morning too?
Oh my god, I do.
I have something I have to do an hour before as well.
Oh my god.
Okay, everything will be fine.
Bro, I'm so out of it.
um uh uh what else am i gonna what else i want to talk about uh uh uh next week i have a sponsor oh and also i'm next week i am streaming uh metal gear solid delta that's right Shout out to Nexy because that was actually a charity auction reward where she wanted me to play Metal Gear finally and I will be calling Mint.
Mint.
Oh my god, you know my brain was so frazzled.
I almost called the other name.
That's how tired because I've never done that before.
That's how tired.
Like it was literally like I had I like buffered it.
I had it like my brain buffered it and stopped it instantly but the it showed up in my head yeah it actually like came up in my head when I was like mid and then like in my head it was the other name I I've never the thing is I've never done that before too that's how fucking tired I am like my mental my mental blocks are like not working properly uh Yeah,
no, like, I'm super scared.
My mental blocks are actually, like, like, they're being broke.
Like, it's, like, we're down right now.
Like, no one has been upkeeping it.
Um, um, um, I didn't say it, though.
I, I, the name appeared in my head.
That's why I was like, mint.
so um anyway anyway um what was i gonna say uh we're gonna mince gonna be like in a call with us while we're playing with rage baiter i don't know what we're doing i forgot that she her schedule we were planning on this week and she's like this is my schedule and then and then i was like yeah because like she was double streaming and everything and I was like bro and like she had meetings at night and she's like oh I could do it after my meetings which was like 10 p.m.
like it was like what was it like it was like 9 p.m.
or some shit she's like oh I could do it after I was like bro I'm not scheduling this after your meeting for your third stream like
yeah I was like you're fucking crazy bro we'll do it next week man we'll do it next week so um um so yeah so we're i don't know what day i need like ping you and be like what day are we doing it again wait what day because like i'm going by her schedule because her schedule is more fucked up than mine right now um uh you'll finally get the i don't think i will i think i'll just be still very confused uh uh uh i think it was super chat thank you but and also we have a sponsor next week and after that i don't know what was the stuff with my schedule i'll figure it out later um um what else oh there was something else i want to talk about i'm trying to run oh also i want to say i'm really proud of my team for being incredibly flexible and we didn't really have one tricks it was i will say um it was very hard to fucking figure out what the fuck to do with our limited when Loki didn't work because Yuzu's hero pool was basically like what Yuzu's hero pool was she can only play four supports
because she had two days to learn four supports which is already really good she like okay three days maybe I don't know I know I knew like she had two to three days to learn as many supports as possible and she learned but at that time because that was a day late uh because i was a day late to joining the server uh she ended up she learned invis gambit loki and adam and only those four characters um and because of that you know she didn't know that i was gonna be gambit she didn't know that i was gonna be gambit and kiki was gonna be invis like that was the main we're gonna be like these were the main rules that we're gonna do and yes kiki already knows how to do the other supports as well so Um,
it was very restricting because like Yuzu could only do low key or Adam and she can't play anything else after that.
So, um, because like, you know, they started batting Invis.
They started batting Invis and then started playing characters that counter Loki.
So we were, and then also Gambit.
They started batting Gambit Invis.
So we're like, what do we, we're, so that's why I had to go on rocket.
Cause I was like, I was like, okay, I'm gonna go on rocket.
And I had to go on Luna because, like, I'm the most flexible out of all of us.
So I was like, okay, it's okay.
I'll be rocking it.
I'll be Luna.
You can play Adam.
We're going to have to figure out how we're going to, I'm going to try to coach you on the fly on Adam after you played Loki for how long for so many hours.
I'm going to be live coaching you right now in the finals.
It's live or die.
first place but that's no pressure though you know how like because at first she started she was resing in the middle of everyone as adam when i said oh play for res and after the first match i was like hi i had to i was like you suit you gotta hide you suit and then she improved so fucking fast incredibly fast too afterwards um sink or swim you had no pressure by the way um in the second game she improved a lot um and then i also obviously i had to call out soul bond too because like you know the soul bonds also helped out a lot with like all the other ults i was like so bond so bond us now like so i obviously i had to do live coaching on the fly to tell her when to use the abilities too because like they actually saved our lives like the soul bond saved us too for a lot of things um and also isa too isa was very versatile you know she wasn't supposed to be our tank player she was supposed to be like the tps player and then we put on tank because we're like we need a tank like so i'm
really happy with how versatile everybody was like you know she wasn't even supposed to play tank she was like the namor player um but we're like we ain't playing namor here because other teams know how to counter Naimore, but they don't know how to counter.
They don't really know how to counter.
So she tanked really hard.
Isa did a really good job tanking as well.
And she was very, like, you know, she, her IGLing was also pretty, like, she, not co-IGL, like, because she helped with co-IGLing.
Like, I don't know, is it called shock calling?
It was more so of target calling.
She helped out with target calling, you know?
So it helps out a lot with target calling because, like, people, things, sometimes things weren't dying and you needed someone to target call.
But I had to take over at one point because we're target-tiling the wrong thing.
Like, they're like, get this guy that was 20 miles, like, for it.
I was like, no, kill the thing on the cart, guys.
Ignore, I know they're like, kill the support so they can't heal the thing on the cart.
And I was like, guys, it's over time.
Like, guys, it is over time.
It doesn't matter if, like, it doesn't matter if we kill the support.
We have to kill the thing on the cart.
We can kill the support later after they're trying to run to the cart because it's over time and they have to touch the cart.
Yeah.
I had to like, I had to redirect the target calling.
I was like, no!
I was like, cart, guys!
That tilted me so hard.
um that took me so hard because there was like a full there was like a fucking hat full hp emma just chilling in the car and then she like held a oh no it was a full hp emma on the point while everyone else wanted to chase kills in front of us i was like guys we need to cap the point please kill emma like like kill the thing on the point first before we do anything else like like um um but yeah no isa did a really job heavenly our fucking secret weapon like um like i said he signed up cps but we put him on take because he was our best take player like he was he was our he was our actual best take player because we had no other even though it was his off roll it was the best tank player um and And,
you know, they didn't expect the secret weapon, you know, the, um, the, you know, that he was supposed to be, like, our other DPS player that we, like, hid.
That's what I was saying.
Intel is key.
I didn't want to leak any of our, any of our strats.
I was like, hide your profiles.
Intel is so important in these.
This is why pro players, all pro players hide their match history because they don't want, like, and that's why pro players don't stream their scrims.
It's similar in any hero shooter.
Like, Overwatch, they do the same thing.
Because, you know, there's, like, a hidden black market for players leaking scrims to other teams and stuff like that.
Like, they'll be like, bro, you got that scrim.
Like, yo, bro, didn't you scrim this team last night?
Can we, like, borrow, can we watch that replay?
Like, like,
the dark web of, like, like, exchanging.
this team later that you're going to face in the in the tournament so we're like we can and and you know your face you scream that team and we're going to be facing them so like can we like you know like i'll give you our scrim vibe and our scrim replay and you guys give us your their scrim replay so like you know for it yeah it's like the intel war like like info swapping yeah exactly nothing is more valuable than information and i heard like other teams were also just Like what so that's why it's like private your profiles private your profiles and don't talk about what we're playing because obviously Maybe some one was like we don't want you know,
there's like chat hoppers and stuff like that.
So I was like worried about people like leaking our comms leaking the Our comps that we had so I was like, okay, I'm gonna do these bad guys look at I'm gonna type on type out our comps and stuff if this happens to you know have the comps we had because i was like no leaks no leaks it was best of one like like what can i do in that situation it's literally whoever has the most information wins a best of one because that is scary like i'm so happy we didn't get domination because i don't it's so hard to adjust in domination um Yeah,
so, I mean, we did get domination versus Amelie's team, but like I said, um, um, it was so, so close, because in domination, you have to adjust so fucking fast.
Um, yeah, um, but yeah, anyway, that was the tournament.
Yeah, I think that's everything about the tournament.
Yippee.
I am so tight.
thank you guys for uh for like all the support for that tournament i'm so sad that you know my i lag so hard on the last you know the finals game like because of youtube like youtube i had to like you i can't have see i told you guys bad luck you know the most hyped final two three games and then YouTube fucked me up like I told you I told you I've had such bad luck so that's why I was like I was just like guys I don't trust myself anyway I don't trust my luck anymore like
um uh like it was like monkey paw you know you can win the tournament but you can win the turn but no one can watch it happen like like that's so fucked that actually is so fucked um yeah equivalent exchange right there yeah but your stream gets cursed um
to look at other povs to see like the pov of me in the pack um um what else i want what else do i want to talk about hmm uh i'm gonna watch a lot because of the youtube that view plus one congrats on the w thank you super chat thank you thank you recycle i really appreciate it um but yeah like i said thank you all guys i really appreciate you guys all shooting me on like gosh it's crazy it's crazy i've had so many things happen to me throughout this year and i really appreciate all the good things that come my way and i don't want to take it for granted you know i i don't want to take it for granted and um thank you guys thank you guys all for watching and i love rivals so much i i took it way too seriously i know I know you guys like,
we're like, Toki, it's a for fun tournament.
I'm like, you don't understand.
It's rivals.
I was like, you don't understand.
It's not, it's not just for fun.
It's life or death.
Like, yeah.
Rivals are die.
Yeah.
um but yeah i'm i'm just i'm just you know it's been a great time yeah i had a good time all right i'm gonna call it here i'm gonna call it here i know this was all just a rival's discussion but you know i'm celebrating my post win post win guys this is a post win Discussion with,
blah, blah, tired.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, yeah.
Before anything else, guys, before anything else, this is very important.
This is very important.
I got something to show you guys.
Well, it is very important.
But because I won my tournament, I am allowed to keep on chilling.
Did you guys know that you still have one week left to pre-order your very own Doki Bird controller?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, you want me to keep on winning?
Why not pre-order the Doki Bird controller right now?
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, damn, that looks so good, guys.
It could be your, you could have, you could order it right now.
He said, guys, did you, did you hear about the Doki Bird?
control anyway guys um yeah i'm passing up i'll never forget the shill that's right i'm a business woman um anyway i'm actually gonna call it here i want to go to sleep um waiting room might be late or i'm just gonna pawn it off to my manager to make it um most likely i'd be like make this waiting room Oh,
I want to make, I'm going to make bulldog noodles to celebrate.
Yeah!
I got spam.
Okay, I know like I shouldn't be cooking.
I don't, um, you know, fuck it.
I'm going to cook.
I don't want to make, I'm going to make bulldog noodles to celebrate.
I'm going to make my carbonara bulldog.
I didn't eat dinner yet.
I'm going to make carbonara bulldog noodles.
And then I'm going to put mozzarella cheese on top.
And then I'm going to get a yum, yum, yum, yum.
All right.
Hey, guys.
It's always up here, everybody.
And eggs.
And scrambled eggs, too.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Yeah, but moving around.
Get that blood flowing.
I'm like, what are you getting?
What's that liquid inside our bodies?
Get that blood flowing.
Stay up for me and Tibet because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.